地球のみんな！
自撮り、よくするかい？自撮り
俺はね、あんま好きじゃないね。自撮り
こうね、カメラを自分に向けて
（カメラシャッター音）
お”ぇぇぇ…
なんかー、自撮り嫌いなんですよねー
なんか、もうね気持ち悪いね
僕あの、自撮りがちょっとね、あんまり好きじゃないんですけどもー
こうねスマホのカメラ
スマホのカメラあると思います
で、このカメラの機能！
パシャッと撮りますと
（カメラのシャッター音）
写真撮る人には分かると思うんですけども
画角がね、ちょっと狭いんですよ
もっとね広く撮りたいって思った人
いっｐ※♪△💲☆×
がかかっ！
画面がちょっと狭いんで
もっと広ければいいなって思った人
たくさんいるとおもうんだ
そんな君たちに今日は
朗報だ！
LOFTで買ってきました
こちら各種スマートフォン対応の
ユニバーサルクリップレンズ
簡単に言えばスマホにこうやってつけるレンズみたいなやつです
レンズの画角が広がるんですよ
こういう魚眼とかね、ワイドな画面とかになるんで、普通にiPhoneで撮るとこんな風になるんですけども
これをつけると、こういう風に広く撮れると
こういうとても優れたものが今売っています。
え～凄い！すごい！スゴイ！交換用のレンズもついてる！！
これで一回写真撮ってみます！
ヴァ¨ァ¨…
画角は全然広くなります。
もうこれさえあればね、結構広く撮れると思うのですけども…
俺はもっと‼もっっと‼‼‼広く撮りたい！
お前たちもそうだろう？こんなごときで満足してたらまだまだNon!Non!Non!ですわ
あっ、ちなみにジュースは飲まないから、炭酸水で我慢してます。
もうこういう感じだよ？
で、これ一つだけ付けても、これだけの画角で撮れるならば
この魚眼レンズをたくさん重ねて撮ると
おそらくスマートフォンの限界までの画角の広さに成ると僕は思ったので
今回スマートフォン用の画角が広がるレンズを5個準備しました
画角の広がるレンズを重ねておいていくわけですよ！
そうすると多分なんですけども
写真一枚とったらね、もう360度カメラみたいになると思うんですよー
いや、間違いない！俺の第六感がそう言ってるから…
とりあえずレンズ全部出しましょう！
（～早送り～）
問題はこれをどうやって重ねるかなんですよね～
これ重ねてやっていくか！きたきた！！みんな来たぞ
これが今最高の画角！わぁぁ！！
これがスマート/わぁぁ！！
もうこのレンズはもう滅多に見れませんからね！たぁぁ！アンビシャス
もう撮りましょう！撮りましょう!これがスマートフォンの最高峰の画角です！
ご覧ください！行きます！ハイチーズ！
カシャ📷
その写真は何故か周りが黒く
映ってはいけないものが…
映っていた
周りの黒い部分が多いから多分魚眼レンズじゃダメなんだな…
というわけで魚眼レンズは失敗に終わったんですけど
次はワイドレンズで世界さいほうこうの…
世界「最高峰」の画角を見せてあげましょう！
まぁ、これが普通にとったとき
で、ワイドレンズを付けるとこうなります。
おぉ！！広い！
というわけでワイドレンズならひょっとしたら黒い部分が少なくなりそうなので…
ちょっとワイドレンズ×５でやってみましょう！
これはもうガムテープとかで重ねた方がいいレベルだな…
これ、やばい！やばい！やばい！来てる！これはヤバいよ！完全に来ました！！
皆さん　　　　スマートフォンでこんなレンズ見たことありますか？もう一眼レフみたいな感じですよ！これ！
こんなのないですよ！早速撮ってみましょう！　　　　ハイチーズ！